guys I have a confession to make
I was wrong I was very very wrong
[Music]
Caleb Maddox is right
YouTube automation is is the greatest
opportunity of our and I'm gonna tell
you why I think that have I changed my
mind on Caleb Maddox this course at all
no however I saw the light with Andre a
financial youtuber who's really blown up
and he used to be a magician but now he
teaches personal finance and if that
confuses you welcome to the club but
here I am a chemical engineer talking
about fakers so fair enough that's fine
I'm not mad at him for going from card
master to financial whiz in fact I find
him pretty entertaining to be honest I
think he makes some really compelling
content I have a problem I'm a financial
minimalist which means I like to save
money but I just want to just really
highlight how brilliant this automation
process he's implemented here is he's
YouTube's automated the research process
which is just incredible at least for
this video we're going to talk about
today today we're talking about Andres
video called ten highest paying jobs you
can learn without college and it has 1
million views ok it's one of the biggest
videos on his channel and in it he is
gonna tell us you know how to make how
to make seventy five thousand dollars or
more but recently a viewer tipped me off
that maybe maybe Andre didn't do so much
research himself maybe he was relying on
someone else so someone sent me this
makeit article they wish to remain
anonymous it was a CNBC maked article
called the ten highest paying jobs you
can get without a college degree all pay
more than seventy nine thousand dollars
which know is similar but that doesn't
mean anything okay when we go on we find
that actually Andre has automated really
nicely here he's really implemented the
Kaleb Maddox visionary process right
we're not gurus anymore visionaries and
what would a visionary do you know
you out of me your research research is
one of the most time-consuming parts of
a YouTube channel guys it's hard to do
good research so why not steal it right
why not steal it let's let let me let me
give you a little thought experiment
look the reason you get credit as a
youtuber when you do a video it part of
it is you know your presentation but
part of it is your research you know if
you're a finance guy it's cuz you're
you're you're a whiz with all the facts
you're you're aware of all the facts
you've done your own research but again
that's the most time-consuming part so
how about instead we automate it and
that's exactly what Andre Jake did now I
understand if you're a little skeptical
in my claim here but let me build a case
for you so first of all we have the
order and the jobs that he lists okay
because Andre Jick gives the following
list CNBC gives that exact list number
10 media and communication equipment
workers media and communication
equipment workers number nine power
plant operators number nine power plant
operators number eight elevator
installers and repairers coverage
elevator peeps number seven power house
substation and relay electrical and
electronics repair number seven our
house substrain and electrical and
electronic repair one transportation
storage and distribution managers and
the number one job on this list is
transportation storage and distribution
managers he automated it but maybe
you're not convinced you say Stephen
Stephen maybe they were just looking at
the same Bureau of Labor Statistics and
you'd you'd get that pressure because
while CNBC says they analyze their own
data and Andre Jackie has a similar
thing he cites the bureau labor of
statistics he went in to the to the
straight to the bureau and crunched his
own
numbers he crunched his own numbers yes
he did yes he did or at least that's
what he wants you to believe but when we
go closer into the exact language that
cariann Renzulli uses when describing
these jobs she's the one who actually
wrote the article back in April we find
that Andrej uses very similar language
on the video he he made in November
right and remember does Andrei cite CNBC
does he say hey guys I got all this
research from CNBC no no no he never
cites them because because that would
defeat the point of taking credit for
someone else's work so check it out
here's a few examples of things that he
took straight from the CNBC makeit
article that he never cites
and he directly says them as if he
researched it himself and he actually
just knows this off the top of his head
because yeah he's that he's that kind of
guy he just knows this stuff maintain
and distribute the electricity amongst
all the generators and they also control
the flow and the voltage of electricity
to meet consumer demand depending on the
time of day but you will need a
four-year apprenticeship program which
is usually sponsored by either a
contractor a union or an industry
association specialized in inspecting
maintaining and repairing electrical
equipment of the power stations to
become one though is not particularly
easy because you do need a high school
diploma and a lot of employers do want
to see some courses in electronics
whether that's from a community college
or from a tech school and you will
usually start out as an electrician to
get some experience first all this
reminds me of like a word what's the
it's like a word for this I don't know I
was thinking automation but that is that
right Siri defined plagiarism plagiarism
means the practice of taking someone
else's work where ideas and passing them
off no I don't think that's it I think
it's automation these guys control the
flow of electricity by maintaining the
Transformers the converters and the
circuit breakers and you only need a
high school diploma as well as a
certification from the North American
Electric Reliability corporations system
operators certification program these
guys control the control rods that
generates the
electricity they monitor that turbines
and the cooling systems to go along with
it I mean this is this is just
ridiculous
you know you gotta you gotta admire the
awesome this guy he wants to establish
himself as a finance guru and how you
gonna do that by reading how you gonna
do that by doing your own research you
have to take credit for what other
people do look guys I'm telling you I
mean in the past I've always you know
tried to tell people where I get my
ideas from and you know get them from a
variety of sources but in the future I'm
just gonna take books like this the
person in the situation great social
psychology book have any of you read it
no so I probably could just you know
just summarize it for you and say that I
did the research and you guys would
probably believe me and then I could
take all the credit and then I could be
the Guru I mean you really have to hand
in this guy he's got a good hustle going
on and if you don't believe it's making
him money oh it's making him a killing
he's got a patreon where people pay him
eighteen thousand dollars per month to
get up to date you know
his stock picks because you know he's
the guy who does his own research
honestly the people I feel bad for
people like Cary Ann or Enzo Lee who's
who's writing this article doing all
this research do you think she got a
million views not a chance
she did all the research but people like
Andre they can just come and get get
easy pickins right they can they can
learn the thing not give credit for ten
like they they had this idea themselves
retitle the video to be almost identical
to the article sounds good and look guys
I'm not gonna pretend Andres the only
guy who does this a lot of people do it
like I said I like his content I just he
doesn't he didn't do the research for
this video and I think that's a problem
I mean and the fact that he doesn't cite
the article once not in the description
not in the video itself is insane to me
the funny thing is he mentioned CNBC but
CNBC actually did a profile about two
weeks ago about exactly this guy and
he's earning two hundred twenty thousand
dollars per year and he never mentions
the actual article he took all his
information from and not only that he
also that the part where he lists the
Bureau labor of statistics for the jobs
drives me up
wall because what it's trying to imply
is oh yeah I did this research look at
me I'm in the Bureau of Labor Statistics
website I'm in the dot-gov I'm deep in
the dot cup doing my own research here
when in reality is ripping off cariann
Renzulli
sucks sucks to be a writer right now
you're basically a scriptwriter for all
these youtubers who are gonna take all
your all your ideas and research that's
tough it's tough anyway that's a little
quick one I'm gonna change everything
I'm doing
Caleb Maddox was right I I've just got
to say this clearly the way to get
things done and I'm changing I'm
changing everything about my operation
here because we're not gonna lie this
has just been an awakening for me
amazing stuff I've got to stop doing so
much research I mean I'm wasting my time
honestly I should be like Andre I'll get
a million views and have $18,000 and
patreon supporter I'll better produce a
lot more videos to actually if I just
make it an article into a whole video
never give credit Oh automating the
research process I can't believe I never
thought of it
Caleb Maddox is a visionary he sees into
the future this is our future well
thanks for watching guys I hope you
enjoyed just a little quick one for you
for the boys click Subscribe if you're
in the visionary gang and I'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
[Music]
for the common
[Music]